conférence de presse du maire de mario
paul qui se poursuit donc comme je
disais et l'afrique il ya encore 100
mille personnes qui sont coincés à
marioupol et puis on attendait de savoir
la position de l'ukraine sur
l'éventuelle prise de la ville par les
rues c'est ce que confirme le président
russe poutine bruno daroux le maire de
mario paul demande un cessez-le-feu
durable sur
le complexe là où seraient retranchés
plusieurs milliers de combattants ce
d'ukrainiens et quelques civils aux
siens mais en fait ce qu a dit vladimir
poutine c'est que marioupol était tombé
globalement aux mains des russes à
l'exception affectivement de ce complexe
métallurgique d'azov stahl et lavelanet
mirepoix tina dit j'estime qu'il n'est
pas nécessaire de lancer l'assaut final
contre ce complexe nous allons à siéger
il a même dit même pas même pas une
mouche ne doit pouvoir passer on dira
que c'est un siège très très fermé donc
là le maire de marioupol en a parlé à la
fin d'un obstacle bon lui évidemment
réclame un cessez-le-feu durable au
moins 24 heures pour évacuer
effectivement les civils puisque donc ce
complexe va être confronté non pas un
assaut final mais un siège extrêmement
hermétique donc le maire de marioupol
souhaiterait que tous les civils
puissent sortir et qu'il ne reste que
les 1500 à 2000 civils ukrainien mais en
battant le soldat ukrainien pardon il
combattons ukrainien absolument vous
avez raison mais évidemment il dénonce
un peu la perversité des autorités
russes qui en fait en ne stoppant pas
les les tirs contre le complexe
d'azov talent en fait empêche ces
évacuations des quelques centaines on
sait pas exactement de civils qui se
trouve toujours au lard et
malheureusement fait une tactique qui a
déjà été employé par l'armée russe en
d'autres endroits à grozny en syrie
c'est à dire on assiège ce qu'ils
peuvent sortir et on les laisse sortir
selon des critères effectivement bien
particulier
tant mieux pour eux et pour tous ceux
qui peuvent pas sortir un moment même
s'ils sont si vide ils sont considérés
comme étant combattants et là évidemment
c'est un sort funeste qui les attend
voilà le le sort est beau ce talent et
de sa stalle il a aussi parlé de la
ville de marioupol des civils qui
restent qui restent bloquées merci
beaucoup bruno daroux pour ce compte
rendu